yeah welcome to this video we're playing
a cough let's play the drum bosque I
really barely played that before yeah
probably the shelter Smith haha Scizor
this isn't played too often them not
that I know why I think maybe you fire
simply
what are we had opening we should be
back to you too or I'd like to play
Queen G for the general idea at least if
I take care taking seems wrong to me
this sort of helped some intend age for
the style of la la huncha Todd let's
just drop it back try to place afore
maybe can play see if I if this could be
a actually the problem of all this yeah
this could be a problem okay Quincy
force was the idea all along ok probably
g6 young castles I have Bishop h6 I mean
this is really moving this Bishop a lot
am but it's winning in exchange it's
there for castles Bishop h6e must play
g6 give up the book so Wow okay I didn't
really expect that one what about Knight
c3 here is the symbols speed up
development
came it's not think too long here King
evade is not the most ammonia smooth
ever some nights III shouldn't be that
terrible if it captures Bishop takes it
looks nice and if it takes d4 take d5 so
maybe night before as an idea then I
then I wanted to Castle long yeah really
completely non theoretical game here
from move 3 at least for me I never saw
Bishop e7 okay not much choice I guess
now here knight c6 Queenie for it's not
too bad yeah should I take or to take or
not to take that's the question yeah
I'll probably take it okay III here
that's what 95 yeah I must play 95 396
Bishop a six wins okay maybe f5 f5 looks
like we'd move a bit but i can't play 95
I thought just 95 don't think that this
would have been too terrible okay but
anyway what about f5 just nayak wink
wink wink wink and clean we're home
you won't know hmm where am I going with
this piece maybe maybe here after all
yeah okay this must be okay Millie all
the way back to e1 looks weird at the f3
I know Knight d4 something looked looked
yet okay babe f4 you can just take still
a maybe five but this looks very
weakening okay let's let's develop stuff
Ian you can think for quite a while here
problem and I b5 was a good move
actually okay but this is still still on
Bishop g5 also yeah okay but this is
good it threatens to take and Bishop
before winning the Queen and there's
also Bishop g5 still in the mix is
pieces don't coordinate very well we had
the King on a fade that's the problem
I'm not sure what is playing now 96 is
really a terrible threat
mmm okay if I take it when four minutes
probably okay let's take first not to
think too long just F for you from their
form how to i want the bishop on before
I want to win this Queen it's not not so
easy okay let's play keep it simple
exchange his best piece
and then we should be to look you want
something like that Queen takes probably
now we take should be fine
yep taking the noid
oh wow if I go before is this too much
it's too much i would if i take and play
before i can play both actually
maybe not complain I deform I could have
taken before I'd it's a pin simply now I
can plan out your form I thought this
one attacking the knight and the rook
and the bishop oh my that's much stuff
hey now Queen f6 though is a move but a
queen e 8 mate so I cannot lick we have
six yeah this is actually important this
Queenie ate meat
ya know move problem
black resigns yeah no no move oh he saw
piece picking up a couple of a couple of
moves yeah now he stopped examining no
idea sometimes they also back up and
want to look a bit yeah the question
really is here what to do I don't really
like to exchange this this somehow feels
wrong I mean he's got this this
immediate idea and night fo and whatever
I mean I really like to keep the bishops
on because this is somehow stepping on
each other's toes but after c5 is
probably not so bad Queen g4 even even
castles isn't so clear this this
exchange sacrifice it's it's I'm week on
the dark squares and he's really quick
now knight c6 coming and i only have the
Queen out this isn't so clear it's a
possible sec okay King f8 I really don't
like it it seems not it doesn't seem
necessary really it's probably still a
bit bit unclear and this now looks looks
good I just have a strong attack him and
then various ways alright thanks for
watching